c'est une des attractions les plus
courus de paris plus d'un demi million
de visiteurs font chaque année la queue
pendant des heures pour visiter les
catacombes le côté obscur de la ville
lumière un dédale lugubre où sont
entreposés à 20 mètres sous terre
les ossements de plus de 6 millions
parisien
mais ces galeries souterraines ouverte
au public représente moins de 1% du
réseau des anciennes carrières de paris
tout le reste est interdite secret
inaccessible sauf pour un groupe
d'initiés qui en connaissent les entrées
les cataphiles gaspard duval en fait
partie il a découvert les catacombes
il ya une dizaine d'années depuis il y
descend au moins une fois par semaine
c'est venu naturellement voilà quand
j'ai couché vous là bas tout de suite
les lieux monde j'ai eu envie d'y
retourner
je me sens bien et c'est un endroit que
j'aime beaucoup que je trouve très beau
la mine et pendant des siècles pour en
extraire de calcaire le sous-sol de
paris est devenue un gigantesque gruyère
alors ça c'est ce qu'on appelle une
plaque de rue en fait on est sous la rue
vercingétorix les galeries creusées sous
terre constitue un véritable monde
parallèle une deuxième ville sur la
première et les gens qui marchent au sud
ignore totalement ce qui se passe sous
leurs pieds un trésor minérale constitué
d'interminables couloirs et de salles
décorées et sculpté au fil du temps par
les carriers et par des générations
cataphiles
kim séduit c'est l'environnement c'est
le calme c'est là c'est la beauté des
lieux
mais les lieux sont moins en moins calme
internet a eu raison du secret et depuis
le plus en plus de jeunes descendent
jackman semaine dans les catacombes pour
braver l'interdît se donner des
sensations fortes et surtout faire la
fête dans un lieu insolite en conscients
ils se rendent pas compte de dangerosité
des lieux qui voit les copains descendre
ils entendent les copains descendront du
coup ils disent qu'ils peuvent le faire
une hausse de popularité qui inquiète
les policiers chargés de la surveillance
des lieux unités spécialisées
le groupe d'intervention et de
protection mieux connu sous leur surnom
les cats appliquent ils patrouillent les
catacombes tous les jours à la recherche
des contrevenants carte descendre dans
les anciennes carrières de paris est
interdite passible d'une amende
mais les katas flics ont surtout un rôle
de prévention et de sécurité
oui c'est dangereux comme on peut le
voir mon équipe et on a des cas ce qu on
a des chaussures adaptées continuer
d'appeler la plupart des katas fils eux
descendent sans casque sans frontale et
avec des plantes qui sont plus ou moins
rustiques les anciennes carrières de
paris constitue un formidable réseau de
galeries souterraines
un labyrinthe de plusieurs centaines de
kilomètres dans lequel il est très
facile de se perdre
on est on est on est dîner c'est la
seule des lanternes
c'est avant la salle des hommes
lorsqu'ils sont dans la ferme a cédé et
lorsqu'une personne ses gardes dans les
catacombes tout un plan de secours se
mettent en branle
on vient de faire ça et ça ouais y
applique les cataflics avec des maîtres
chiens les pompiers mais aussi les
cataphiles les plus aguerris moi je veux
bien aller fouiner par là alors on
recherche un gars qui se seraient
égarées il ya un jour et demi à peu près
le réseau est passé au peigne fin
il ya quelqu'un chaque salle chaque
couloir
chaque pluie ya quelqu'un finalement le
fêtard imprudent a été retrouvé à
l'autre bout des catacombes après y
avoir été perdu pendant plus de 48
heures
l'augmentation de fréquentation des
catacombes a aussi d'autres conséquences
malheureuses les nouveaux venus les ris
tout comme on les appelle ici ignorent
bien souvent les us et coutumes à suivre
sous terre ils sont surtout moins
attachés à la préservation des lieux
j'aurais changé à la fois les catacombes
et la population il ya des choses qui se
font détériorés par les gens qui sont
pas toujours délicat il ya des plaques
qui se font voler petit à petit le
réseau effectivement perd un petit peu
de sa valeur
et comme il n'y a aucune volonté des
autorités de préserver cet endroit là le
patrimoine s'en va petit à petit coin
alors parce qu'il sent menacé
gaspard duval entrepris de photographier
des catacombes dans leurs moindres
recoins
comme ici la salle des cuillères au
début j'ai juste voulu restituer ce que
je ressentais je trouvais les lieux
tellement tellement beau tellement
tellement tellement intéressant que je
voulais en garder une trace relativement
fidèle ou du moins ma vision à moi et
petit à petit oui j'ai constitué cet
immense photothèque qui qui recouvre
l'ensemble des catacombes souparis plus
de vingt mille clichés patiemment
éclairée à la bougie
un travail de moine un travail de
mémoire sa garde la mémoire des lieux
tels qu'ils étaient ou tels qu'ils sont
et peut-être que des générations futures
seront heureuses d'avoir ces clichés
gaspar a publié un livre est mise en
ligne ses photos il
constitue peut être aujourd'hui le
meilleur moyen de visiter les catacombes
en toute légalité en toute sécurité et
surtout sans risque de les dégrader
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
dans les anciennes carrières de paris